Guten Tag, mein Name ist Kanar, ich bin als Assistan als Synthetikier. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Annamneskische Projektuschwürren, Kursumablauf, würde ich Ihren Personen nicht schon da drin erfahren. Wie heißen Sie?
Ja, Doktor, mein Name ist Veena, ich tut mir leid, aber ich kriege sehr schlecht Luft, deswegen kann ich vielleicht nicht so gut auf Ihre Fragen antworten.
Ich habe schwere Luftnoten.
Okay, ich kann Sie nicht mehr. Okay, ich werde Sie jetzt die Monitor anlegen und ich gebe Ihnen das Sauerstoff auf.
Das wäre sehr gut, ja.
Ja, dann vielleicht, wenn Sie besser führen können, wir unsere Gespräche weiterführen.
Okay, mit Sauerstoff geht es ein bisschen besser jetzt, habe ich gemerkt. Ich versuche, so weit es geht, Ihnen zu antworten.
Ja, ich beeile mich auch.
Aber ich habe immer noch Luftnoten, aber es geht jetzt. Ich hoffe, ich kann Ihnen antworten auf alles.
Ja, können Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen langsam bestapieren?
Ja, mein Name ist Herbert, schreibt sich H-E-R-B-E-R-T, Herbert. Und mein Nachname ist Veena, schreibt sich W-E-H-N-E-R, Veena.
Veena, wenn man sich genau gewohnt, Herr Veena.
Erster, achter, 48.
Wie groß und wie weit sind Sie?
Also ich war mal 1,75 m und wieg, ungefähr 90, 92 kg.
Was wird Sie so schreiben?
Ja, diese Luftnoten habe ich seit jetzt ungefähr 3-4 Stunden massiv.
Und wie Sie sehen, kriege ich auch in Ruhe keine Luft.
Und das war jetzt vor 4 Stunden, weil es jetzt noch kein Problem für mich war.
Ich hatte, was vielleicht vorher war, also ich hatte heute Morgen schon starke Kopfschmerzen gehabt.
Und auch ein bisschen Übelkeit, Schwindel.
Und wenn ich atme, merken Sie auch, dass es so, als ob da voller Schleim wäre, die Brötchen,
aber ich habe nicht so viel Ausfuhr.
Wenn was kommt, dann ist es eher so schaumig, was ich abhust.
Haben Sie viel Pieber, Süddeichfrost?
Ich habe es jetzt nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich nicht warm an.
Wie fühlen Sie sich allgemein? Fühlen Sie sich krank?
Also jetzt aktuell seit heute Morgen, es geht mir sehr, sehr schlecht. Vorher war ich einigermaßen fit.
Ist es Ihnen dafür einen Auslöser aufgefallen?
Ich weiß es nicht, Herr Doktor. Ich kann es Ihnen nicht genau sagen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Brötchenmärzchen vielleicht?
Also ich kriege Schleffluft, aber so richtig Schmerzen kann ich nicht sagen, nein.
Haben Sie so Schleffluft, als ich war, denn erst mal gehabt?
Das ist das erste Mal, dass ich solche Probleme habe, ja.
Sie haben keine Brötchenmärzchen und ja.
Ich kriege nur Schwerluft, dann Schwer.
Sind Sie verlesst?
Verletzung habe ich nicht, nein. Ich habe keinen Unfall gehabt, nein.
Ja, vor dem Luftnot, haben Sie etwas Schweres gehoben oder?
Kann ich nicht sagen, nein, ich kann mich nicht erinnern, als ich etwas gemacht habe.
Und ja, haben Sie Probleme mit dem Schlucken?
Ich habe nicht gemerkt, was Herr Doktor.
Vor 4 Stunden etwas Medikamente oder ungewöhnliches gegessen?
Ich habe viele Medikamente, also manchmal bin ich da auch nicht so ganz sorgfältig
und lasse mal ein paar Tabletten weg. Ich weiß nicht, ob es vielleicht daherkommt.
Ich habe viele, viele Tabletten und manchmal vergesse ich dann auch, um Tabletten einzunehmen.
Zuletzt habe ich mich über Profäne genommen, aber die Rücken schmerzen es bei mir kroneicht.
Da habe ich immer Schmerzen schon gehabt.
Und wenn Sie inhalationen, haben Sie Probleme atmen?
Eigentlich habe ich von Atmen keine Probleme.
Haben Sie Probleme?
Ich glaube schon, dass es Herzschnellpunkt momentan ist.
Ich spüre das richtig hier.
Muss man sich übergeben?
Ich habe Übelkeit, aber ich muss nicht erbrechen.
Haben Sie in den Beinen Schwellungen bemerkt?
Aktuell habe ich keine Schwellungen in den Beinen.
In der letzten Seite haben Sie eine Langreise gemacht?
Nein, ich war zu Hause jetzt nicht verreist.
Sind die Schmerzen zu Hause aufgetreten?
Schmerzen habe ich jetzt nur im Rücken, deshalb habe ich seit Monaten schon.
Aber im Brust habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Ich habe die Luftnot zu Hause aufgetreten.
Keine Luftnot, jetzt seit 4 Stunden habe ich Luftnot.
Haben Sie keine Probleme mit dem Rachen?
Im Rachen?
Kann ich nichts sagen?
Wie sieht Ihr Ausflug aus?
Ich habe die Lunge brodelt, aber ich habe nicht so viel Ausflug.
Wenn etwas kommt, ist es ein bisschen schaumig.
Aber es ist jetzt kein Eiter oder so.
Ich habe keine Ausflug wie bei Bronchitis.
Mein Kopf ist ganz rot, wie Sie sehen.
Ich habe Kopfschmerzen.
Haben Sie Blutdruck?
Ja, ich habe Blutdruck.
Ich nehme auch 4 Tabletten gegen Blutdruck.
Sind Ihr Blutdruck gut eingesetzt?
Manchmal ja, manchmal nein.
Ich kontrolliere nicht so oft.
Ich gebe Ihnen einen Blutdruck.
Ich nehme 20 zu 140.
Jetzt werde ich Ihnen einen Blutdruck senden.
Was für Medikamente nehmen Sie gegen Blutdruck?
Ich habe hier Kandesatan.
Amlodipin.
Thorazemitz.
Aspirin 100.
Kohlesterin.
Siri ist leise.
Ich habe Kohlesterin.
Ich habe den Rückschmass Ibuprofen.
Insulin-Medikamente.
Seit 5 Jahren.
Ich habe Tabletten, aber jetzt hat der Haus gesagt, ich muss insulin spritzen.
Können Sie hinlegen?
Es wird schwierig, wenn ich mich hinlege.
Ich würde lieber sitzen bleiben, wenn es geht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Masseilassen?
Gehen Sie Toilette oft?
Ich muss nur ein bis zweimal raus.
Wie ist die Verdauungssysteme?
Ich habe bis heute keine Schwierigkeiten gehabt.
Ich habe nicht vergessen.
Ich meine, es verändert sich in der Schutulverhaltung.
Bis gestern war alles normal.
Wie ist die Appetit?
Heute schlecht, sonst ist es zu gut.
Ich esse viel.
In der Listen-Seite haben Sie etwas genommen?
Oder sind Ihr Gewicht immer gleich?
Ungefähr gleich.
Können Sie gut schlafen?
Ich habe Schlafstörung.
Aber die helfen nicht.
Ich kann durchschlafen.
Ich schwöre sehr oft auf Nachts.
Seit einigen Jahren?
Ich habe Stress bei der Arbeit.
Ich habe früher Stress, aber jetzt habe ich keine Probleme.
Ich habe keine Probleme mit der Arbeit.
Ich möchte wissen,
wie ist Ihr Gesundheitsstand?
Sind Sie allergisch gegen Medikamente?
Nein, habe ich keine Allergie.
Sind Sie vollständig?
Ich meine gegen Kindheitskrankheiten.
Corona?
Ja, andere Kinderkrankheiten weiß ich nicht genau.
Solange ich mich nicht erinnern kann.
In den letzten Wochen haben Sie eine Erkältung gehabt?
Nein, habe ich keine Erkältung gehabt.
Ich habe keine Erkältung gehabt.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Schon lange her.
Da bin ich am Blindarm operiert worden.
Da war ich noch junger Mann, 22.
Dann ist die Gallenblase operiert worden.
Da war ich auch so ungefähr 50 Jahre alt.
Das ist auch schon über 20 Jahre her.
Könnten Sie bitte die weiße Operation nennen?
Die Gallenblase ist operiert.
Ich habe die Steine.
Ich möchte wissen, was Sie über Ihre Lebensgewöhnheiten sind.
Rauen Sie?
Ich habe mal geraucht, aber aufgehört.
Da war ich mit 30 Jahren.
Als ich in Rente ging, habe ich aufgehört.
Vor zehn Jahren habe ich aufgehört.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Ich habe eine Schachtel und eine Schachtel.
Drinken Sie Alkohol?
Nur Bier.
Begegelt oder elegant?
Ja, ich habe das.
Ich habe das.
Begegelt oder elegant?
Ja, ich trinke zwei oder drei Flaschen pro Tag.
Zwei oder drei Flaschen?
Ja.
Seit wann trinken Sie?
Schon immer.
Ungefähr 40 Jahre und 50 Jahre.
50 Jahre bestimmt schon.
Das ist recht viel.
Ich trinke nur Bier mit wenig Prozent.
Das ist kein richtiges Alkohol.
Alkohol schadet Ihre Gesundheit.
Sie müssen darauf achten.
Ein bisschen.
Ich habe keine Krankheiten.
Deswegen empfehle ich Ihnen.
Ich nehme diese Fragen nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Mit Drogen?
Nein, ich habe keine.
Ich möchte wissen,
ob Krankheiten Ihre Eltern hatten.
Ich habe keine Krankheiten.
Aber im Vater war es nicht.
Er ist relativ jung gestorben beim Verkehrsunfall.
Die Mutter ist gestorben.
Auch jetzt schon lange her.
Die hatte Zucker, auch wie ich.
Und die ist am Schlaganfall gestorben.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe zwei Geschwister.
Die sind noch jünger als ich.
Aber zu denen habe ich keinen Kontakt mehr.
Wissen Sie nicht über Ihre Gesundheit?
Nein, weiß ich nicht.
Sind Sie schon Rente?
Ja, ich bin Rente.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich war lange Bürgermeister.
Ich war Politiker.
Das war sehr stressig.
Damals war es stressig.
Aber jetzt seit ungefähr zehn Jahren.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Wie haben Sie mit Ihrer Frau?
Ja, mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, die Kinder sind schon erwachsen.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, die haben keine schweren Krankheiten.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Ich habe eine kleine Tochter.
Machen Sie regelmäßig sportliche Aktivitäten?
Eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe auch Kegeln mit Freunden.
Was für Sport?
Können Sie nicht Kegeln?
Ich habe nicht gehört.
Können Sie bitte eine andere Wortwirkung?
Das ist so ähnlich wie Bowling.
Ich habe für mich alle Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas?
Es geht schon ein bisschen besser.
Aber ich habe immer noch starke Luftnoten.
Ich glaube, Sie wollen mich auch im Krankenhaus behalten.
Ich nehme mich an.
Dann muss ich noch anrufen zu Hause,
dass Sie Bescheid wissen.
Ich habe noch eine andere Wortwirkung.
Es geht schon ein bisschen besser.
Dann muss ich noch anrufen zu Hause,
dass Sie Bescheid wissen.
Das kann ich Ihnen sagen,
wie lange ich im Krankenhaus bleiben muss.
Das sei von Ihrer Befundung,
Ihrer Untersuchungen.
Ich vermute, Sie haben
können entstehen. Deswegen, ich sehe es schon... Was ist das Lungen, Frau Doktor? Ich kenne das nicht Lungen,
was ist das? Ist das was Schlimmes oder... Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, dass
Sie hierher gleichzeitig gekommen sind. Ja, das kann gefährliche Situationen führen, aber wir können
einfach mit der Medikamente, die Sie beschwerden, wieder abgehalten werden, Sie machen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Also geht es wieder weg, meinen Sie, ja? Ja, aber Sie sollten immer Ihre Blutdruck mehr achten,
vielleicht sollten Sie Ihre Beweglichkeit mehr achten.
Wenn die Luftnot besser wird, mache ich alles, was Sie sagen, Frau Doktor. Nur die Luftnot muss besser werden.
Das werde ich machen. Sie bleiben hier und wenn es passiert, wir können einfach eingreifen.
Ich komme Ihnen gleich zurück. Was sind noch für Untersuchungen geplant,
für heute, dass ich meiner Frau sagen kann, was noch gemacht wird? Können Sie mir da helfen?
Ich werde erst die Korpferlische Untersuchung dann ein paar Labor und Bilgewende verfahren,
ich würde ein EKG schreiben. Je nachdem Ergebnisse von Untersuchungen würde ich Ihnen sicher die Diagnose mitteilen
und ich werde auf die Therapie weiter planen. Okay, machen Sie mich gesund, Frau Doktor, bitte.
Ja, natürlich, wir sind deswegen hier. Vielen Dank.
Die dreht sich alles, wenn ich aufstehe.
Auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10. Ja, 1 bis 10. Und können Sie mich genau beschreiben?
Ja, ich habe 6 bis 7 kochende Schmerzen, vor allen Dingen hier vorne.
Und mein Kopf ist ganz rot, wie Sie sehen.
Haben Sie geschwollen in der Beine? Nein, das hat die Frau Doktor schon gefragt,
waren Sie nicht geschwollen. Was gibt es noch für Fragen? Haben Sie viel getrunken, gegessen,
normal, trinken, war auch normal. Haben Sie alle Vorerkrankungen gefragt von Patienten?
Ich habe ja noch ein paar Sachen stehen.
Und andere Vorerkrankungen gibt es?
Ich hatte immer so einen Art Schlaganfall, aber es dann an einem Tag wieder weggegangen,
also war eine Tier. Ja.
Und dann hat er noch obstruktives Schlafabnösendrom, hat Maske immer nachts, C-Paps.
Und hat wegen einer Krebserkrankung bekommt er noch so eine Chemotherapie einmal pro Woche.
Und hat deswegen eine, kriegt er ab und zu Bluttranslusionen auch.
Das ist anähmisch.
Ich habe Herrs Rasen oft getroffen.
Sind Herrs Rasen oft getroffen? Nein, nur heute gemerkt.
Im Moment.
Ja, so herz pochen, klopfen.
Irgendwörche, Aspirin, Aspirin, Andere, Blut, Ferdinums, Mitil.
Das ist kein Moment da.
Wasfas, können wir als als geistige Anfangen, Sultan?
Ja, können wir machen gerne.
Wann haben Sie letztes Mal Blutübers getragen?
Vor einer Woche.
Vor einer Woche?
Ja.
Ambulanz, ambulantische Immoterapie.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen einen neuen Patientin,
Herr Herbert Wiener vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte schön.
Herr Herbert Wiener ist 75 Jahre alt, 1,75 m groß, 92 kg.
Herr Wiener, schüttelt sich bei uns wegen für 4 Schutunden
und hat sich erstmals aufgetreten.
Er hat eine Ruhu-Dissene mit Klopf-Fen-Den,
Frontale, Kopfschmerzen, Neusea und Vertigo.
Er hat eine Ausführung vor.
Herr Wiener hatte diese Beschwerden erstmals.
Früher hatte er keine Beschwerden mit Atmen und Herz.
Auf die Nachfrage gibt er an Herzrasen zu haben.
Herr Wiener hat gesagt, dass er seit 2 Jahren durch Verstörung
und hat keine Schütterung.
Er hat keine Schütterung bei der Arbeit und im Alltag.
Er hat eine Nektur, aber diese Beschwerden
sind bei ihm langem Zeit bekannt.
Herr Wiener hat keine Allergie und hat sich erstmals
gegen Corona verursacht.
Herr Wiener hat eine Nektur, aber diese Beschwerden
sind bei ihm langem Zeit bekannt.
Er hat eine Nektur, aber die Schütterung
ist nicht sehr gut.
Herr Wiener hat eine Nektur, aber die Schütterung
Er ist extra für die Schütterung.
Früher hatte er 50 Jahre alt.
Seit 10 Jahren hat er die Schütterung aufgehört.
Er trinkt regelmäßig bis drei Flasche Bia seit 50 Jahren.
Seine Mutter hatte Diabetes mellitus.
Sie ist an Apoplex gestorben.
Er hat zwei Geschwister, aber er hat keine Kontakt mit ihnen.
Er ist jetzt in Rente und er ist Bürgermeister.
Ich bin der Programmmeister, vor zehn Jahren,
hat er in Rente gegangen.
Er ist verheiratet, lebt mit ihrer Frau.
Er habe zwei Erwachsene, die gezwungen sind.
Er macht keine regelmäßige sportliche Aktivitäten.
Er macht eine Kälberin.
Er hat eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Er ist in der Klasse verwendet.
Er hat eine Dienste, die mit der Akute öffnet.
Er ist differenzial diagnostisch.
und akute Lungenembolie in Metraht, meine Ferdachdiagnose zur Abkühlung,
würde ich als den Patienten körperliche Unterzufon,
bei der körperliche Unterzufon, erwarte ich Arhöfte Bulutturuk
und in den Lungen erwarte ich Volte Russell Beräusche.
Wir sind die Volten Russell Geräusche, die Sie bei ihm hören, beim Lungenemodem.
Ralsch, auch. Wie meine Sie? Inspiratorisch.
Sie haben gesagt, Volte Russell Geräusche?
Ja, inspiratorisch.
Ja, das ist inspiratorisch.
Volte Russell Geräusche gibt es auch bei Pneumonie zum Beispiel.
Ja.
Und wie sind die beim Lungenemodem?
Sind die gleich wie bei Pneumonie? Kann sein, aber manchmal sind die ein bisschen anders.
Es gibt so zwei, also die feuchten Russell Geräusche.
Fein, meines.
Fein oder grob?
Fein.
Was würden Sie erwarten beim Lungenemodem?
Beim Lungenemodem erwarte ich eine große Lange.
Die meisten sind grob Lasegeräusche, ja?
Grob Lase.
Ja.
Und er habe keine Beinzwählung.
Und ja, ich werde alle Laboren unter so einen Grund durschieren.
Ja, das ist groß.
Sie haben ja schon mal Anfang den Patienten Sauerstoff gegeben, haben Blutdruck gemessen.
Ja, echt.
Und haben Sie eben was zum Blutdrucksenken gegeben, was haben Sie gegeben für Blutdrucksenkung den Patienten?
Kapto-Pril Tablet.
Okay.
ACMA.
Kapto-Pril, erzählen wir.
Ist das erste Wahl bei der Hypertensis im Entgleisung Kapto-Pril?
Ja, wir sollten die...
Mit Lunge dem vor allem, was ist dann so, was wird man da eher geben?
Normalerweise, wir sollten Nitroglycerin in der IV-Infusion geben.
Ja, oder auch als mal in der Notambulanz auch mal Spray, kann man machen.
Oder man kann auch Kals-Im-Alterkulissen geben, so Nitren-Debinen oder nicht-in-Vertibine-Vögel geben.
Als dabei ist es geklappt, richtig.
Aber Nitro wäre gut, auch vor allem beim Lungen-Adem, wäre es gut, glaube ich.
Gut, und dann hören Sie was weitermachen, wenn es nicht sinkt oder nicht so gleich gut geht.
Was kann man noch machen beim Lungen-Adem bei Hypertensis im Entgleisung?
Ja, die Ritken.
IV-Infusion geben.
Genau, ja.
Gut, das wären so die ersten Maßnahmen, die Sie bei Hypertensivank dessen machen.
Worauf sollten Sie achten bei Hypertensivank Leisung?
Wenn der hat jetzt Plutokap von 240 bis 240, da haben Sie gemessen, ja?
Ja, hier sind die Blutberuch nicht schinal sinkt.
Warum nicht?
Ja, ein Stegen, eine Hirnendämme, dann ja schinal päsent ward.
Ja, richtig, ja.
Gut, jetzt haben Sie ein bisschen gesenkt.
Jetzt haben Sie gesagt, machen Labor unter so, obwohl nachgucken Sie beim Labor bei Lungen-Adem.
Gibt es da spezielle Laborwerte, die Sie bei Lungen-Adem helfen beim Lungen-Adem?
Ja.
Oder warum machen Sie Labor bei den Patienten?
Das hat den anderen Grund.
Ja, ich glaube, es ist ein Auschulus meiner Pardachdiagnose.
Troponinwerte und Dedima und LDH BNP würde ich bekämen.
Ja, richtig, ja.
Ich habe schon AKG geschnitten.
AKG hat einen Tarekaden-Synos-Rhythmus, ja?
Ja, Synostaschkade.
Genau.
Und jetzt haben Sie noch Labor abgeschoben.
Was machen Sie noch normalerweise?
Also neben Körper-Ichen-Aussuchen an Untersuchung machen Sie noch was?
Labor, AKG und?
Echo, wovor würde ich?
Was machen Sie?
Echo.
Echo, ja, okay.
Und was macht man auch noch aus?
Weil manchmal ist es nicht ganz klar, ob es vielleicht doch Pneumonie ist oder nicht.
Natürlich, ich möchte auch noch nicht.
Was erwarten Sie bei Lungen-Adem im Röntgen?
Bei der Lungen-Adem ist es nicht so gut,
weil es nicht so gut ist.
Wir haben auch eine andere Röhrung,
die wir in den Vaskulen haben.
und Cardio-Toracic Index, kann ich es erhört sein?
Ja, okay. Sehr gut, ja. Okay.
Gut, dann haben Sie das Echo gemacht.
Was erwarten Sie beim Echo?
Ich habe das Echo erwartet.
Die Linken haben wir schon.
Cardiakum, die Ejectionfraktion,
kann es gesenkt werden.
Ein bisschen.
Kann man manchmal sehen, als das Ursache drin ist.
Was denken Sie, was andere sehen,
hat Hinweise auf die Koalition Schreiben, Rechtsheitsbelastung
oder auch Linksheitsbelastung mit Vorhauf, D-Latation usw.
Manchmal kann man sehen.
Manchmal kann man sehen,
dass die Koalition Schreiben,
die vielleicht Ursache sein könnten,
für das Lungen-Ödeum.
Was denken Sie,
war bei den Patienten der Auslöser für das Lungen-Ödeum?
Können Sie bitte die Frage wiederholen?
Warum hat der Patient ein Lungen-Ödeum bekommen?
Ist es bei jedem Patient mit Hypertonie so möglich
oder erwartet?
Oder warum ist es bei ihm passiert,
dass ein Lungen-Ödeum bekommen hat?
Das ist ein Lungen-Ödeum.
Die Abente ist mehletos.
Die Blutdruckwerte kontrolliert
mit der Reichmedikamente.
Das ist ein großer Risikofaktor.
Ja, stimmt.
Aber was ist bei den Patienten vielleicht passiert?
Das hat er Ihnen auch gesagt,
als Sie ihn gefragt haben.
wegen Transpension.
Das kann eine Sache sein, aber die setzt eine Woche her, deswegen ist das wahrscheinlich, aber
indirekt haben sie recht, wenn die Transpension wegen Anämie gemacht worden ist und immer noch eine Anämie hat, dann ist es so, dass er leiter dekompensieren kann, ja.
Bei der Herzensbezirrenstilatent ist. Das kann sein. Aber was ist bei dem Patient noch passiert?
Sie haben ja gefragt, ob er Medikamente nimmt und so weiter. Was hat der Lene gesagt?
Er hat gesagt, dass er Medikamente nicht gut angestellt ist.
Ja, was hat er noch gesagt?
Er hat trinkgefühle. Er trinke viel Alkohol.
Ja, also zwei bis drei Flaschen Bier ist in Deutschland nicht viel, ja? Das ist normal.
Das ist normal in Deutschland. Das ist kein Alkohol.
Aber was hat er, er hat gesagt, das ja, aber er hat irgendwas gesagt, so ganz leise mal, mit den Medikamenten.
Hat er die Regeln mit sich eingenommen?
Er hat gesagt, er macht Medikamenten manchmal so, vergisst er sich, hat er gesagt.
Ich hab das nicht gehört.
Er hat sich durchgesagt, manchmal die Medikamente, da ist er nicht so genau, lässt sich auch mal weg.
Also er hat seine Medikamente nicht genommen. Das ist bei dem die Ursache.
Incompliance von Patienten und dann hat er wegen der fehlenden Blutdruckmedikamente,
ist er höpertensiv entgleist mit diesen ganzen Nebenfaktoren, die auch eine Rolle spielen natürlich.
Alle Risikofaktoren gibt es aber, Alta, Alkoholik, Brügel, Rauchon.
Also was er auch noch hat, das habe ich jetzt hier nicht gesagt,
weil ich habe den Fall von der Klinik mitgebracht, also den Patienten, den ich so mitgebracht habe.
Der hat auch eine chronische Nieren-Nizifizierung, das hat er auch.
Ein Faktor für die Kompensation vielleicht, wenn es eine Nieren nicht so gut arbeitet.
Also er hat viele Baustellen, Anämie, Diabetes, Krebs, Zylöde, Erkrankungen, Hämotherapie.
Ja, genau. Was machen Sie, wenn der Patient mit Nitro nicht gut wird?
Also Blutdruck sinkt nur ein bisschen, das ist auf 180 zu 100. Was machen Sie dann?
Oder hat Angst?
Ich werde eine Kardiolobe checken.
Das ist gut, das hilft immer.
Ne, da gibt es noch andere Medikamente, die Sie einsetzen können, ja, so Notfallmedikamente.
Kennen Sie da welche, wenn die Drohne nicht hilft zum Beispiel?
Ja, jetzt fällt mir leider nicht ein.
Also was man machen kann, ist Urapidil, genau, hat der Kollege schon geschrieben,
oder auch zum Beispiel Katapressin, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist, aber Katapressin ist auch Medikament.
Frosemann hatte schon die Kollegin gegeben, hat ein bisschen geholfen, aber nicht viel.
Meistens ist es mit Nitro und Frosemann in der Regel zu beherrschen oft, ja.
Was ist so noch eine Differenzialdiagnose bei Patienten, die so mit Luftnot kommen
und so Brodenlaus, so richtig so rastlgeräuschig, die man schon so ohne Stethoscope hören kann?
Was ist da manchmal eine Differenzialdiagnose, wichtige Differenzialdiagnose?
Asthmatic.
Asthmatic, ja, genau.
Da gibt es ja auch den berühmten Begriff Asthmacardiale auch, gell?
Weil es manchmal ähnlich klingt, ja.
Kann manchmal auch Mischpilzern von beiden.
Da ist Doktor Mahmoud Experte dafür.
Deswegen gibt es ja gleich Kortison und Lasis gleich beides.
Stimmt oder stimmt nichts?
Nichts.
Das ist mein Toller.
Doktor Soutan hat Pneumoleuk und deswegen ich ...
Aber die sind notarzt.
Sie kennen sich mit Notfall gut aus.
Aber war so eine gute Vorstellung, oder?
Ich glaube, das hat alle wichtigen Sachen gesagt.
Aber wenn ich Lataniwörter ...
Hat sie benutzt?
Nein, hat viele benutzt, Lataniwörter.
Ich hätte zum Beispiel, dass Vertigo auch Schwindel gesagt.
Weil Oberarzt muss nicht unbedingt Vertigo hören, aber ist gut, wenn ich es sage.
Ja.
Jetzt sind alle Wörter, wenn man das nicht sagt.
Müssten alle in Lataniwörter gesagt werden, ja?
Und sagen Sie auch, was haben die Kollegen letztens gesagt, als ich gefragt habe?
Bauchschmerzen zum Beispiel, ja?
Abdominalgie.
Das sagt kein Mensch hier in Deutschland.
Burus Schmerzen.
Also sagt kein Mensch Abdominalgie, das heißt Bauchschmerzen hier in Deutschland.
Vielleicht den Düsseldorf heißt das so, aber die wollen die Leute ein bisschen verrückt machen.
Ich glaube nicht so.
Alle Berichte schreiben die andere Prüflinge.
Manchmal mit Wattbegriffen, manchmal Umgangsprecher.
Also manchmal muss man auch die deutschen Begriffe nehmen.
Also gerade sozusagen das klassische Abdominalgie, das benutzt kein Mensch in Deutschland in der Klinik, ja?
Das sagt man nicht.
Und klingt nicht so gut.
Eine Kollegin hat gesagt, der Prüflinge ist schon eher.
Also man kann also Prüflinge schon eher, dass man benutzen kann.
Aber Abdominalgie, no way.
Also das ist kein Prüflinge, in dem man der normalen Medizin arbeitet hier in Deutschland.
Jetzt soll ja niemand extra hören.
Aber machen Sie so wie die das wollen, ja?
Nicht wie es gut ist, machen Sie so wie Sie es wollen.
Ich können nicht planen.
Wir haben andere Stimmung bei der Prüfung deswegen.
Stimmt, dann sagen Sie mal, oh, Entschuldigung, ich wollte Abdominalgie sagen, statt Bauchschmerzen.
Ihr könnt es nicht sagen.
Oder machen beide, sagen Sie, Pazän mit Bauchschmerzen oder auch Abdominalgie, dann ist gut.
Dann ist alles zufrieden.
Ja.
Okay, aber es war gut.
Also ich denke, dass für die Prüfung kein Problem sein sollte jetzt.
Ja, das ist gut.